[Applaus]
[Musik]
tokio was für ein start erst gar nicht
zum flugzeug ausgestiegen und jetzt aus
manchem uncharmante
ich bin patrick rohr ist von der partie
fernsehmoderator 10
hier zu opfern welches buch mit bildern
und texten das land mache ich will
wissen wie die manche hier abendvisite
ich bin froh dass du deine skin sich mit
mir
der dänisch padborg sofort die schweizer
rundfahrt bank
aufgewachsen ist der schweiz erläuterte
breuer japanisch und hatte zieht land
japan kraft darum ist für mich in der
sprache sondern eine kultur übersetzer
ist mein motto audi verhalten trifft im
aster schlürfe finden wir ja zum
beispiel unanständig so entfaltet sich
der volle geschmack von assad erließ
ich kann mir vorstellen dass die
reitsport wird ich freue mich auf das
abenteuer
[Musik]
japan sieg der insel
da stimmt nicht ganz 800 und tiger
[Musik]
zwei millionen tier 2 1 millionen sind
im großraum tokio
dennis hat man im voller fernseher
japanische fernsehen
tracht lustig sehr gut sogar und zu
minute branche als sehr schwierig
die junge frau im heidekreis schweizerin
halbiert bahn ring ihre namen christina
satow parker kristin ist japan ein
großes da sie schon sogenannte tv
personal wurde frieden stollen im
fernsehen startet aus moderatorin
verspielt aus tochter strukturen
politkommentatoren diese spannende
personen parker kristin mit sagt selbst
er aufgewachsen ist of japan als
heimatland vor dem vater allein ohne
eltern ganz große glück hat sie dafür
kann als lehrer
das ist die zahl verständlich werden
terminkalender
mit grafischem der parks tokio also lebt
sprach mit ihr ist fast nicht möglich
gibt import sind völlig sinnlos lukas
[Musik]
und 4
ein eingebauter
ich bin mit meiner siege sechs
kontrolliert vor mit druck haltend und
jetzt hab ich mich gerade fassen und
jugend sind einig
wo ist der bahnhof dahinter aber auch
mit dem fotografieren und fotografierte
das thema
okay okay
und noch ein rahmen mit nudeln films
rahmen also es hat alles drauf aber das
[Musik]
war sozusagen ein rahmen- und einmal ein
dass wir jetzt wissen
das sind die offene platz das habe und
ich das machen fährt michael will die
andere erst seit gut dass ich das finde
ich sagen ja
man denkt immer alles
aber das kann ich jetzt ja genau
trocken und so bringt dem gesichtslose
schauen wo man im gasthof abschotten job
ziemlich speziell geld macht sich
aufbauen überhaupt das mag ich habe
nicht gehört dass man hier kritik da
stimmt doch das erste mit der aok
christine
vegas bietet
jetzt bin ich nicht noch
zum einen auf 270 erfreulichen auf
was das plaudern ok
und das heißt ja ok
[Musik]
minute
dank hilfe
[Musik]
am abend will mit der eines tokioter
nacht aber zeigen bevor es in den job
auch digital designer der live show
produzenten hat derzeit man studiert
derzeit landwirtschaft
er weiß wie man sich dieser stadt bewegt
[Musik]
wird japaner sohnes großes zimmer curry
kreis kelheim einfach nicht macht zum
beispiel statt angst vor gesichtsverlust
hat also durchaus ihre vorteile
produktionskosten nur so am rande mit
golden gate die prostituierte viertel
prostitution ist in den 50er jahren
verboten sind ein paar hundert sie sind
richtig verschachtelt um meistens mit
griffel außen stube
hier gefällt es ist klein die drinks
stammgäste haben ihre eigene flasche
wenn ich hier gast wäre dann hätte ich
meine eigene flaschen würden jede nach
trier kommen
nicht jede nacht vielleicht einmal pro
woche zwei mal
ich habe heute gelernt dass ich es so
betonen muss aber das tor oder gehört
das ist nicht nur eine bahre
ich habe zwei jobs ich verkaufe
secondhand kleider und arbeite hier
verkaufs kleider die kleider kauft in
den usa bringe sie hierher und verkaufe
sie online
reister so viel ja ich besuche meine
verkäufer jedes jahr
[Musik]
das leben in tokio muss teuer seien sehr
teuer
in den usa kostet dieses shirt ein bis
zwei dollar in japan fünf bis
sechstausend yen 50 franken
50 dollar ducati also 52 dollar und
verkaufte für 5000 das ist ein geheimnis
du bist ein guter verkäufer
[Gelächter]
ich würde eine serie fotografieren um
lippstadt heime dann würde ich nämlich
eine box die app review gehabt ich frage
nach der heimat darf gebühren er seit
jahren
tennis ist überrascht dass man sie ab
und zu sehe ich eine melodie
sie gibt auch eine ungewöhnlich seite
normalerweise findet sozial aber
überhaupt für die eigenen vier wände
steig guten tag wird das dich
wiederzusehen
ein paar monate wieder der heime
bisschen älter und das ist 1000 r laden
großartig das ist das was du online
verkaufs nachts in einem webshop
verkaufen und alles ist aus zweiter hand
[Musik]
tokio ist sehr dir
darum hatte lugo wie viele japaner zwei
jobs das ist dran aber nur viel strenger
geworden als büroangestellter geschafft
hat als sogenannte salary man manchmal
konnte ich nachts nicht nach hause ich
arbeite in der firma und schlief in der
vertieften am schreibtisch auf dem
schreibtisch so echt und am morgen auch
ein weiterarbeiten wie oft wie lange
macht es tue das
vermutlich acht jahre acht jahre etwa
acht jahren jetzt hat defizit und armee
für die heute aber es gibt sache nur
selbständige nicht möglich sind
ein eigentlich wohnungskäufe zum
beispiel ohne fernsehkameras japan würde
sagte mit dem webshop in großer traum
wie findest du das weißt du was wohl
liegt ja wo ist das patagonische ich
erinnere mich du hast du so ein system
ohne ein system zu haben ein system nein
kann ich dir helfen
ja ich kann einpacken und jetzt das
shirt ich muss die adresse schreiben
kann ich probiere besser zu schreiben
ja auf japanisch ich kann versuchen
alles sind das chinesische oder
japanische zeichen wurde es ist ein mix
an die japanische zeichnen aber
ursprünglich aus china sehr gut gemacht
ich glaube der name reicht hier hat es
mir zu viel passiere zeichen kannst du
die adresse schreiben
[Gelächter]
was wird ein kunde dem 18 langsam ist so
wird das ich frage ob ich ein paar fotos
gemacht so ernst und englischen vereine
mann
ich wünsche dir viel glück mit deinem
job und in der bar
die roma wurde geboren gesellschaft mit
vielen talente mag
ich bin hinter dem sich schon vorher
beschlossen
nach der ersten woche storchenpaar tag
aufs land fahren im quelle vom bahnhof
china war sicher der weg zum schimpansen
das erste japanische
hochgeschwindigkeitszug wovon ein
schöner netz bis zu 320 stundenkilometer
schnell fort von mächtige macher für die
heimische band obex-mischitz und und
relativ günstig sind chronische wunde zu
rasante meter genau da wo es offenbar
zeichnet ist stört zum wichtige und oft
sekunde knapp präzise gates mit
colina
in japan ist das studium ist ein kreisel
macht also will mit anschluss an das
praktisch alles nachlesen
das lässt und über nacht zum den jungen
mit den hufen
[Musik]
von tokio in zukunft teurer im westen
vor
jetzt sind im autowrack sitzball feiner
kerl
er bildet und im links lehrer
hast du mir was michael linke sieht er
hoffe dass die linke sie look des
spiegels verschoben
[Musik]
wir übernachten ein privates von der
gastfamilie ein jogger im begriffe
tendierten übernachtungs nacht und
morgen werden breakfast of japan ist
sozusagen eine traditionelle hits japan
geschlafen aber foto auf dem boden wo
mit der dame mathe ist kritisch
versteckt sich sehr über andere
buddhistische schreien nordhues auch
dass eine meister japanischer hilfe gibt
plötzlich streckten marktakteure der
miami yamazaki ich sage ihm mit falsches
und erklärt ein paar eingeleitet
eigentlich noch geschwärzt hat sind alle
würden und auch die anderen mut machen
sind aus holz und keine einzige niklas
ist eine cola
ein heizung gibt der japanische hirscher
nicht einmal der waage aber traut mir
danach trotzdem nicht los und vier war
ein festes nachbereitet nimmt maria sagt
o'connor und laserdom behälter die
traditionelle japanische pet flasche
geht es die ganze nacht wunderbar warm
[Musik]
und sein
viele japanerinnen und japaner kann
führt richter war schon bei ritualen und
dann auch noch in schweden bereits
infiziert mit yakuza also mit der
japanische mafia dass nur die böse
stiefmutter
ich wage es zum glück hat seit dem
morgen eine zufällig im online-special
format ist sehr wichtig dabei werden
oder körper sondern auch den geist
gereinigt erst einmal ganz übles
geldmanager sie bald
das schönste tor
herrlich wie ein sportler
wer sie bereit für fortsetzung
[Musik]
gestartet hatte reiss vorwoche tokio die
letzte tag bin ich marine bergdorf im
westen vom land jetzt bin unterwegs aus
onagawa im nordosten
es geht der grund warum ich genau und
die stadt will 2011 hat der tsunami
onagawa komplett zerstört
onagawa islamische staat klicks tat die
sich mancher handy kommt
konami hat alles geschlechtliche mehr
oder mancher sowohl gibt hat man alles
genau
827 lied sind hier zur lage war am 2
statt herzlich funktional noch immer
nicht rund
höfe lied sind weggezogen und mit
zurückkommen hinterlassen zu ein drittel
weniger liegt ausfuhren zunahmen
schon als beliebtes touristenziel jetzt
geht zum zentrum kairos
meine reise begleitet eines günstig und
wir sind immer konnte in silikon achten
am nächsten morgen ist wird er wieder
rief bouchard fortschritten ist der
erste drucker nicht gerster hat täuscht
onagawa entsteht nicht nur mehr sondern
vor allem rund ums alte zentrum an der
hand zum teil haben der letzten jahr
ganz neu aufgeschüttet damit wohnhäusern
zur kunstform wasser sicher sind
als neue zentrum militärs vor der
katastrophe auch meter hat mehr hilfe
schüttet wohnhäuser gc kennen nur latein
und recht traut der bürgermeister seine
zentrum sollen begrüßt werde
die handliche weise fängt man in der
japanischen gesellschaft erst mit 60 an
verantwortungen für viele sachen zu
übernehmen ich glaube dass meine
generation die verantwortung für die
ersten schritte der wiederauferstehung
diese stadt übernehmen soll
in japan gibt es viele regeln die
einschränken wenn wir nach der
zerstörung hier einen neuen ort frei
gestalten könnten sehe ich das als große
chance wieder etwas darüber sagen
einheimische die geblieben sind haben
neue geschäftsideen und junge leute
kommen nun von außen hierher und starten
hier in onagawa ein neues business wie
zb der junge herr mit seinen gitarren
shop dort drüben bringt das tokioter
vorgezogen
[Musik]
mach mit seinem team ganz spezielle
gitarre elektrogitarre frog aber
traditionelle musik und die teil waren
verliebt nicht fragen was war für sie
der grund hierher nach onagawa zu kommen
dieses geschäft aufzumachen und hier
gitarren zu produzieren
als ich das erste mal hierher kam spürte
ich dass diese orte eine starke energie
ausstrahlt die leute versuchten bereits
neue geschäftsideen umzusetzen
die fisch firmen zum beispiel möchten
neu nach übersee verkaufen
so dachte ich diese stadt ist ein
wunderbarer ort um ein gutes produkt
herzustellen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dieser rief ist ein gitarren intro der
schweizer band gotthard
[Musik]
bürgermeister ist ein rocker als
gitarrist in einer heavy metal belt
[Musik]
contador und evans
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich bin also sehr wichtigen rat kann ich
nicht heran
das sind alles aus feiern als konzert
sachsen zunahme wohnen immerhin konnten
sie tiger halten und forscht ohne
privatsphäre
und die neue siedlungen im oberen teil
vor gestoppt sind zwar schön und modern
aber halt da anonym
als vor der wenige gebäude zur lage war
wohl noch ein tsunami entstanden sind
ist spital
update 18 meter über meer und das vor 20
jahren hat herr max glück dass es hoch
genug ist damit für mixed war
[Musik]
ganz kleine taste allerdings doch nicht
wasser ist 18 meter hoch gestiegen
transporter zu geflirtet die ganze
dauerte von spittal patienten dossiers
alles ist alles zerstört wurde
so hoch ist was du damals hoch
spittal hat man noch mit zunahme mit
spendengeld aus der schweizer aufgebot
neu hatten auf der oberste beide steigt
alters und pflegeheim ohne gedrungen ich
darf er fotografiere ich will mir das
allerdings mit meersalz aushilfsjob
verdienen
bitte ziehen sie für ihren einsatz die
angestellten uniform an die wir hier
täglich tragen
wir würden uns freuen wenn sie uns heute
mithelfen könnten gar nicht vorstellen
es wurden menschen aus dem erdgeschoss
weggespült unsere angestellten im ersten
stock kamen knapp mit dem leben davon
das wasser drang ein schwan und
schwemmte sie an die decke hoch
sie hat nur noch knapp 30 zentimeter
luft über sich dann ließ das wasser
glücklicherweise nach sofort nach dem
tsunami war schwierig zu begreifen dass
das was sich vor unseren augen abspielt
die realität war und nicht etwa ein
alptraum
ich glaube dass sie in der oberen
abteilung bereits einige vom personal
kennengelernt haben alle angestellten
die an jenem tag im spital gearbeitet
hatten wussten zuerst nicht was mit
ihren häusern und ihren familien
geschehen war
trotz dieser bedrückenden ungewissheit
sind sie pflichtbewusst im spital
geblieben und haben sich unermüdlich und
die patienten gekümmert
wir lachen tsunami hövel it werkzeuge
sind hat niemals großer spital gebracht
dafür dass platz seines autos platt heim
hallo alle miteinander wie schon am
morgen angekündigt haben wir heute
besucht guten tag konnte dann schlage
ich vor dass wir nun unseren übungen
machen
auch die füße bewegen
[Musik]
man hat mehr platz gebraucht wird sollte
sanader war geht es wie in ganz japan
namen trägt auf die einzieht ist das
schön
anders sieht das problem wirklich zieht
die geburtenrate rapide sinkt
darum sind der trend alles andere als
gesichertes japan dass mancher hier
immer älter werden und hat verschiedene
gründe haben tassen zelts und uns zu und
hat systemisches vor der baustoffkonzern
bis von in deutschland älter bis zum tod
gehören händler glaubt dass der
sozialplan im einzelfall und immer
weniger junge geht gibt's einmal weniger
personal für die alten hatte
[Musik]
analyse würde sich das problem
vermutlich nur wenn es mir zu waren aus
dem ausland kabel
doch da japan zerstörte sind hocherfreut
personal nicht einmal zwei prozent der
bevölkerung sind ausländer
[Musik]
macht sich sorgen sollen sich in zukunft
um die auto kümmern
tendenziell leben die jungen nicht mehr
bei den eltern
alte menschen werden allein gelassen
oft bund eine alte person allein in
einem haus dazu er und ein anderer
gesellschaftlicher trend immer mehr
junge mancher beschlossen und auch
sinnlos labskaus das geht die mit
weniger junge wo heiraten
[Musik]
ich glaube dass es mehr braucht als das
wenn die heute verteilt lebenden
familien wieder wie früher zueinander
finden und miteinander leben würden dann
würde wohl eine bessere gesellschaft
entstehen denke ich es ist wichtig dass
die verbindung wieder gestärkt wird
zwischen einzelnen leuten und den
familien auch lokal im dorf das ist der
richtige weg
[Musik]
diese vorträge für japan sind groß es
ist riesig jahres im land ein drittel
weniger menschen gar und die meisten von
ihnen sind dann im pensionsalter
ich habe keine ahnung welchen kollaps
vor dem land lauter verhindern
ich habe als flakhelfer lagerfeld lehrt
und 14
die arbeit ist 100 jahre alt
sie hat in ihrem leben viel zu
[Musik]
us and intensive thaksin norden
zwei wochen bin ich jetzt der tennis mit
der reisebegleiter haben wir derzeit
viele türen aufgemacht und viele
begegnungen ermöglicht und erzählt über
die japanische kultur
doch herzog die schweiz ins büro
nicht
am bahnhof tokio nahmen abschied von dem
vorhaben mit hilfe lokaler besetzerinnen
[Musik]
bevor ich mit reisen kann ich mit
allerdings am bahnhof noch im job
gewechselt ich darf helfer ein
shinkansen spots eine von einer
hochgeschwindigkeits zurück das tönt
jetzt lockert es aber gar nicht wenn man
weiß was für woche aussprechen bahn hat
einen super wie soll verteidigungs für
markt gibt einen crashkurs wichtigste
seite ist olympia da haben wir es
richtig faltet sie und wenn wir uns nur
richtig habe 6
und dann leer ich mir meine zukunft
passagier richtig empfangen
ja ihr habt richtig gehört
reinigungspersonal besatzung und
passagiere mit magic
und dann geht's los drei minuten
passagiere zugestiegen und dann rund
commander zum nutzer
wie ihr vorgänger und 63 stil in fort
richtig und rasch passiert dir vertraut
[Musik]
naja
es ist von der ganze wagen zum glück für
das 2
ich glaube das ist mark toner sehen
o
das wird heiss geschafft aufrollen mini
kollegin hat es geschafft sechs monate
lang ist wie alle ihre kolleginnen und
kollegen des billigen bevor sie zum
ersten mal allein zu verputzen die
versteuerung
die rostocker sein
der zug war pünktlich ob du jahr hat den
linken farc rechneten ihm minuten
verspätung
[Musik]
bahnhofvorplatz nbc eine raumstation
vor 20 jahren hat man jetzt japan sehr
kontrovers diskutiert die eingefunden
hatten schandfleck für die historische
stadt die andere sind begeistert vom
futuristischen look
[Musik]
kyoto schon sehr lebendige moderne ist
otto hat das einzige große stationen
historische hahn
[Musik]
der grund dass kinder immer ein alter
teil hat es dass kloten zweite weltkrieg
als einzige große station vor den
bombardements ist verschont geblieben
es ist blöd sind zypern die wichtigste
wochen im jahr im vierten frühling der
vorfall am nabel der cisco ob das model
kinder ist fast unmöglich
im roboter nao das hat's noch nie
hier ist der lift für männer und frauen
getrennt
großes vertrauen
denn der name nine hours stunde herz
hotel will mehr für 1 8 in der stadt
mehr braucht als zehn stunden leistung
für toiletten zu schlafen eine zum iftar
alles ist es wesentlich dass geparkt hat
es wenig platz natürlich ist das bistum
finke wenn ich jünger war ich würde
wahrscheinlich möglichst viele hatten
aber nach der jetzt bin ich ganz froh
dass vorläufig war ein 8
[Musik]
nachtisch kurz aber dafür habe ich
geschlafen
ich bin froh in schongau bis 6 uhr
morgens mit tage mit mir nun
übersetzerin teuer mache ich nicht
erwartet story okamoto eine der weniger
kampfkunst trainerin sozialplan geht
yokohama durch 82 schießen aikido seien
sei ein aikido lehrerin und reiter sagte
dann er sagte stets schwarze gut das
heißt und das ist ja sehr schnell klar
werden
jetzt gab es sein den sitz meditation
währenddessen sitzt du so die augen sind
nicht geschlossen
[Musik]
eine erste lektion in kampfkunst ist
erst mal kunst gehindert kampf
[Musik]
40 minuten im lotussitz mich nicht
bewegen
grades bürger gedanken und widerlager
spannende erfahrung
[Musik]
richtig schnüren und zentriert sie ist
immer sehr wichtig das finde ich schön
aber man kann ich voll dabei
ich muss mir meine fotos wir mal ab
verlieren ich finde das gehört wohl
einer sitzt auch so und beziehe zu der
menschen und anders sieht wirklich so
teilten ganze geschehen will ich noch
nie gemacht und drohen mit der aktion
wahrscheinlich mehr im werk wurde
strasser besonders halten wenigstens ist
die harmonie ist die energie aikido ist
also der weg die energie zu
harmonisieren zu harmonisieren mit der
natur und jedem einzelnen individuum und
ding das auf der welt existiert die
ganze welt
sie bewegen sich im ballett
alle sind klagt sie
niemand redet es wurde
du arbeitest ohne worte folgen sie dir
einfach wie könnte ich die natur und all
die schönen dinge erklären
sie sind einfach schlimm du musst sie
sehen und fühlen wahrnehmen
das system konnte das selbe es gibt
nichts zu erklären für mich ich werfe
sie uns sie müssen das studium
[Musik]
der weg des aikido ist zu akzeptieren
ohne sich daran zu klammern
ohne widerstand er gibt es noch nicht
wenn du aggressiv bist und ich werde
auch aggressiv dann knallte
wenn du fit bist brauche ich aber nicht
wütend auf dich zu sein
ich akzeptiere es und denke es um
bisschen zwei personen
ich kann dich und mich aber auch aus der
perspektive einer dritten person
beobachten wie wenn ich uns in einem
film sehen würde wenn du also wütend was
brauche ich das nicht persönlich zu
nehmen
genau das geschieht auch hinter sitz
meditation yoga fühle nicht verstaubt
eigentlich würde fotografie das heißt
eine von max als bild sagen je aus diese
quote würde aikido mein leben verändern
ich weiß nicht was möchtest du denn
verändern
genau darum geht es beim aikido langsam
verstehe durchaus so viel mehr sport es
ist ein persönlicher moniert mit
körperlichem training auf situationen
richtig zu agieren
klarheit respekt und faszinieren die
frau
der ice fahrt kurz noch einmal einen
vierjahres tische tempels community
verkehrt um dann auf den meister wer
weniger das land anhand seiner lehre
ich mache einen kreis und den stein
du machst den äußeren in verbindung dazu
darum alle menschen sind verbraucher
sein öffnet das herz
nichts ist für die ewigkeit ich kann ein
neues muster machen wenn ich wählen
jede tätigkeit ist in sich perfekt wenn
man die ganze energie auf den augenblick
lenkt das wichtigste ist dass selbst man
wendet sich dem inneren des selbst zudem
waren selbst mit dieser spirituellen
gesunden haltung bringt man den körper
die atmung und den geist in ordnung
geist und körper genießen
diese drei punkte zu trainieren
das macht das leben mit seinen aussieht
fürs morgen die stäbchen aus gefühle und
platziert sie rechts
dann öffnet die servierten nimmt die
schüsselchen mit der linken hand von
links her der franziskusschule von
orange gencer gratis westliche besucher
trägern im sensex gedanken ablehnte
darum ist sogar die masse alle streng
ritualisiert jetzt die nächste schüsse
[Musik]
bitte es schneller und still
bitte nicht den rettich essen
läge die stäbchen nicht hin egal was
passiert es den rettich reinigt die
schnäppchen sie zurück in die hülle
trinkt das wasser will das ist die zehn
weise zu speisen alles wird genau und
bewusst gemacht
das ist etwas vom wichtigsten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir wachsen andere daten von roche
genscher
[Musik]
nach den sitz meditation langsam schnell
wieder und wieder
das soll helfen also das hier und jetzt
konzentrieren
doch so einfach ist das gar nicht ich
frage mich was der deutsche da macht und
ich befürchte dass ich mich aufs nächste
treffen dort sachen
ich habe spaß und bin auch im lange
sitzen plötzlich lacht entspannt sammelt
sich die kraft beim tandem dem zentrum
des körpers
hier kommt die kraft hin sein zentrum
ist schlaf ein tandem sollst du stärken
damit seine willenskraft und energie
fließen kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im power ist das virtuelle bewusstsein
mit allem verbunden zu sein ich zeige
dir die innere kraft mit meinem körper
so ist diese ski leichter zu verstehen
und dann seite durchsetze beige wer bist
du dann demonstrierten jetzt was es
heißt wenn man das ist ihm der ganze
energie im zentrum von grad bereit wenn
man richtig atmet und geistig wach ist
wird man sich seiner prächtigen seele
bewusst und entwickelt sich heute nennt
man das auch meint wolters achtsamkeit
das wichtigste band sehen ist sein
zentrum zu finden
und daran
[Musik]
die fotos hatte mal wieder mehr verdient
und münchen idee post sein bedeutet
[Musik]
vorkötter geht - wie drauf osaka
statisches als handelszentrum und eis
vor der wichtigsten schritte der hofer
vorsatz gehabt ist eine vor der
wichtigste im land
[Musik]
busacca pfeift ab die erste sekunde
statt dich sehr lieb ich irgendwie
weniger hektisch aus tokio manche sind
entspannt und recht witzig
[Musik]
junge mann charlie entfernt war
so beobachtet treuer freund und man auf
der anderen seite von glos stand finde
ich dass das symbolische band
[Musik]
ich kann nämlich glaser japanerinnen und
japaner dick ich immer weniger binden
immer mehr liberale aus den bezirken
warum das so ist heute morgen in der
sales bei eben dieser kinder
[Musik]
freude auf das wird auch normal sind
warten der batterien an der bar manager
hat das gab er wird seine freie passt
dann bringt sie zu sehen
ich frage der manager der onyx absicht
würde ich einfach gar fotografieren und
mit ihrer rede ich darf zu erscheinen
diese konzepte mit mehr als einem
jahrzehnt ist das schwierig für einen
mann zu finden
es ist schwierig den ersten eindruck
richtig einzuschätzen
träumen sie von einer familie mit vielen
kindern zwei wären perfekt
sind sie nervös an einem solchen abend
ja ich bin aufgeregt das schön groß und
zwei frauen am nebentisch hatte
zueinander gefunden woran die bosse 25
minuten lauter frauen und männer bin ein
anderer sitze
spätestens dann fällt mir wird übel traf
oder nicht wenn es bis der nicht weiß
wird sowieso nix ist haute gehen ist es
entscheidend
man ziehe komisch düstere telefonnummer
oder man geht zurück zum manager der
deines feedback zum traf der nordlys
coach setzte mit zunehmender im update
auf der suche nach liebe heiraten ja der
möglicherweise schichten
ja wir sind japaner
sitzt im 90 und ist
manche manager schenke und
wirtschaftskrise hat das handwerk bis
gar bringt dich in die gast im internet
[Musik]
das wochen landwirte für möglich wenn
einzig verbringen
[Musik]
warum haben sie heute abend keinen mann
gefunden bilden können warum wohl
heutzutage ist es schwieriger jemanden
am arbeitsplatz kennen zu lernen
der vielen überstunden hat man kaum zeit
leute zu treffen und solche orte wie
hier gehören zu den wenigen
gelegenheiten denke juve ist gekommen
weil sie von freunden gehört hat die
hier früher einmal ihren partner
gefunden haben und wieder zurückkommt
platz normalerweise getroffen hat
herlitz waren über die strahlung aber
irgendwie hätte es nicht richtig gepasst
ihre synchronisation sehr wichtig und
entsprach hergesell pause gegangen
das vorzelt shingo manager wo jetzt die
in ihrer rolle als couch schweren ist
[Musik]
was haben sie von managing gelernt
angst hat auf das äußere zu schauen
sollte ich auf meine gefühle für diese
person achten gefühle sind wichtiger als
das aussehen
[Musik]
shingo welchen rat würden sie
japanischen männern geben und welchen
japanischen frauen männer tauschen zwar
die kontaktinformationen aus aber sie
sind zu tollpatschig in der darauf
folgenden kommunikation frauen urteilen
viel zu schnell
frauen müssten sich nach diesen treffen
mindestens noch zu einem immer
verabreden und zu dem man noch ein
bisschen besser kennen lernen
bis vor nicht allzu langer zeit hat
japan vor allem arrangierte hochzeit
dagegen liebesheirat sind in sachsen ist
das anders
aber mit der freiheit sendet ausspricht
bevor drücken
[Musik]
ein großer modernisierungsschub hat
japan etwa 70 bis new york macht die
stadtwirtschaft regelrecht explodiert
aber trotzdem eine große veränderung hat
tradition hersteller war schon tradition
und moderne kanzler oder stündlich
gehört zu haben
im vierten versuch mit aber herrscht das
jahrhundertealte schnitzt moschitz
lothar klassischen heber 100 jahre alte
theaterform visite praktisch nicht
verändert hat alle rollen waren
verspätet
was für eine figur die sich eher kann
man dem oscar-gewinn zentrale element im
no theater je nachdem wie das auch
spieler kopf habt 306 ist druck für eine
maske bedeutet der maske einen traurigen
ausdruck zu verleihen
und wenn man sie so nach oben richtet
dann bekommt sie einen helleren ausdruck
ein beispiel
hier habe ich ein gesicht auf das
gefaltete papier gezeichnet so etwas
ähnliches macht man auch mit der no mas
[Musik]
ich würde die us army kader fotografiert
am liebsten mit natürlichem licht damit
mir die schöne stimme in ihrem atelier
auf der bilder wirkt bedrückt mich 15
jahre lang präsident lehrgang zum
schluss handball-lehrer paar jahre
später zum ersten mal selber an was
katar für schnitzel und nach 40 jahren
ohne die arbeit jetzt schon macht machte
sie immer noch mit großer hingabe
ich habe den letzten wochen auf unserer
reise gelernt dass man in japan sein
wahres gesicht nicht zeigt wie stark
denken sie haben mich dass jetzt diese
no kunst ist ja typisch japanisches auch
ist sein wahres gesicht zu verbergen
[Musik]
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob man so
direkt an den bezug herstellen kann
zwischen nun dieser japanischen
gewohnheit
aber es gab einen historisch wichtigen
no spieler dessen lehre lautete man soll
etwas nicht aktiv explizite erstellen
sondern implizit spüren dass zum
beispiel gibt es beim auftreten auf der
bühne eine haltung bei der die maske
einen bestimmten winkel hat wenn man
diesen winkel auch nur ganz sanft
verändert wird etwas ausgedrückt
darstellungsweise ist also sehr
eingeschränkt
[Musik]
fast nur aber doch zu japan wo man
vieles nicht zeit sondern es gefühle
damit man versteht
[Musik]
würden sie für mich eine solche maske
vors gesicht halten die fertigen 100
stunden schaffte ja sotschi an eine
maske das wichtigste ist dass jede maske
eine perfekte kopie von vergangenen ist
künstlerische freiheit einer
interpretation dass vertritt nicht nur
kunst natürlich würde ich jetzt die
masken lokalen im einsatz gesehen
sie vermittelt mir ein psyche im kongo
theater
[Musik]
regie kongo für das theater sachse
zwanzigster generation zuvor war hält
das 150 jahr geendet
ich kann nicht viel sehen die maske muss
ich gut polstern weil ich sie
stundenlang tragen behandelt
[Musik]
generation award der b27 generation
führt verwandelt sich jetzt gerade in
der frei
es ist nur von der probe aber trotzdem
sehr aufwändig
[Musik]
tradition seit in dem moment wo der
spieler masken aufsetzen vater geist von
der figur innen drin
[Musik]
jede bewegung ich genau was bleibt sind
jahrhunderte
[Musik]
sie verstecken ihr gesicht hinter einer
maske müssen ihr gesicht verstecken
hinter einer maske wird dafür einen
schauspieler nicht etwas ganz wichtiges
[Musik]
es gibt auch räumen bei welchen man
keine maske getragen wird
aber auch dort muss die mimik des
schauspielers neutral bleiben das wird
unter maske genannt das eigene gesicht
wird dann gewissermaßen als maske
getragen fühlen werden also nie über die
mimik ausgedrückt es ist eher etwas das
aus den tiefen inneren heraus kommt
[Musik]
sehr speziell eine theaterform wo nicht
irgendwie nicht ganz fertig bedruckt von
der eleganz
[Musik]
vorschläge auf okinawa halbinsel wo
ganze gruppe von ihrer insel und fahrt
die sich 200 kilometer weiter im süden
[Musik]
das klima ist tropisch ich komme mit der
works on organic farms besetzt der
freiwillige helfer oft biohof das heißt
ich glaube schafe und darf dafür bittet
bürger wohnen
[Musik]
familien stürmisch aber bis zum rund 14
ich habe den richtigen ort gefunden
ich freue mich sie kennenzulernen
[Applaus]
der erste blick die siege von 13 jahren
von der hauptinsel auf okinawa zogen
ihre qualität besser also festland japan
manche siege offeneren entspannter sie
haben ein zimmer für gäste normalerweise
haben wir jeweils eine person dieses
unkraut musste schneiden gibt es
gefährliche tiere deshalb machst du am
besten so bevor du anfängst danke los
geht's
mit rheine rostige sich schnyder firma
tropische hitze ich falle eines
vermissen 8
[Musik]
meine gastfamilie ist kein richtiger
familie ist ursprüngliche system schafft
aber neben offenburg und der mann aber
ist keramik künstler er hat vor allem
wagen gehörte le mans fokkena wallach
[Musik]
der boden ist nicht nur bei einem
lebensalter sehr fruchtbar zurück wochen
wie verrückt
[Musik]
die amis sind wie viele menschen zog ihn
aber selbstversorger auf abschluss mit
der gartenarbeit starke club
frühlingszwiebel ist 14482 sind oder
heime das ist das okinawa küchengerät
schiri chilli wie heißt das ich gebe
alles für richtig
du kannst kann ich den rest essen
[Gelächter]
der kubanische nacht unterstrich
japanische dies wie pizza gehört die
sprache schwierige geschichte vor augen
aber seit manche hier fühlen sich als
opfer
früher war es ein eigenständiges
königreich dann wurde es für japan
annektiert und die menschen verloren
ihre identität japan gegen japan hatte
china war immer diskriminiert und opa
war war im zweiten weltkrieg der einzige
ort wo ein land gekämpft wurde
die amerikaner haben nicht auf der
hauptinsel gekämpft sie gingen nicht
nach tokio
sie haben es nur bombardiert die
amerikaner haben dann für ihre militär
basen den einheimischen land weggenommen
und sind geblieben
neben der geschichte fühlen sich die
menschen auf okinawa doppelt als opfer
betrogen und benutzt so fühlt sich vor
allem die ältere generation
wegen dieser empfindung proteste die
ältere generation gegen die us präsenz
aber es ändert sich nichts
das hat mit
und am schluss ist doch so richtig
politisch wurde
[Musik]
das mit dem protest materie ganze
märchen sollen gruppe demonstranten buch
von einer us basis blockiert china
kommen übersetzer in weitem bogen ist
die polizei bereits vor ort in einer
halben stunde wird sie beginnen den
platz zu räumen
ich habe mir das gar nicht vorstellen
ist eine andere sätze mit der polizei
friedlich japan dem land wo man morgens
nicht maschine meinung seid das ist doch
nach dieser quelle
sicherheits lied von den minicars intro
karten machen dass sie 20 jahren
und dann kamen zwei polizisten sie war
etwas was wir da machen zu stellen mit
visite vor bedankt
auskunft und verabschieden sich
freundlich doch dann folgt politikers
geschützt
so geht dafür jeder polizist dem ruf
damit lastwagen endlich auf buch stellt
jede minute wird amerikanern nikon vita
buch kostet genau 1000 demonstranten
will immer wieder soldaten freie
belastungen entschied natur kaputt mache
aber über menschen zu tun aber anständig
und die platzt ziel für angriffe
nordkorea ist nicht weit entfernt
[Musik]
die menschen auf den inseln schon sehr
viel durchgemacht davon seien frauen die
ganz automatisch zur kino abrichten und
für gc
[Musik]
geht es nach max dorf von der 100
jährige das heißt und da sein und die
älteste mannschaft aber ich habe mit
einem jahr gehabt macht studierte
vorzeichen
was halten sie von den entwicklungen der
letzten jahrzehnte in japan und china
war unter der kontrolle der japanischen
regierung waren wir immer arm sei die
amerikaner hier sind sind wir reiche ja
ich bin dankbar und glücklich dass sie
uns beschützen
jeden tag züchtig unter anderem goya das
typische gesunde gemüse hier entferne
die insekten und schnecken aus meinem
garten das ist mein morgendliches
fitnesstraining
[Gelächter]
was denken sie über die jungen leute
heutzutage gehen alle gleichen spital
wenn sie ein wenig fieber hat man jetzt
in kinder waren nie im spital
wir hatten kein geld für so was ich
mache ihnen ein getränk mit wildkräutern
und zucker das senkt das fieber das
fieber gilt auch wenn man bananenblätter
ausgelegt wie ein kissen und machten wir
das
schlabitz okinawa handelt sich wie
urlaub
mit nur mehr fluss aus dem westen aber
traditionen verloren alles im garten ist
gemüse das kannst du es
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
na gut
ich esse das immer
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das klingt jetzt organisiert und hat
verschiedene gründe nachttisch eine aber
als klima und die gurte soziale
vernetzung durch hände großen fluss
einmal in der woche treffen sich die
älteste frau der welt gemeinsam vorgehen
er kann sich dann am lage und ihre
kolleginnen als gesundheits check
das projekt nicht nur alt sondern als
und auto und rannte mit seiner haare
dass man hier auf der insel nach dem
grundsatz haare hachiko und hachiko
heißt füllt ihre bücher nur zu 80
prozent mehr chance und seiten her
verstehst du japan
als ich jung war war ich sehr hübsch und
meine haut war wunderschön so alt bin
ich jetzt ich bin jetzt 90 du schwitzt
nicht trocknet ich etwas ab mit dem
taschentuch
gehört dass mich das verlötet
sachlichkeit verlassen
[Musik]
was führt sie zog ihn aber der abschied
fortmann ganze last gelegt
ich glaube trotzdem wieder normal mit
richtig süden 430 kilometer und zwar auf
die insel ishigaki morgens in den mgv
peikert
[Musik]
der absuche vom nächstem oder tumoren
mit zeit der ganzen geschichte das sind
traditionelle bot wo ganz aus holz
gemacht sind und da gibt es keine metall
schrauben oder nägel wenn du metall
nagel verwendest werden die nach 10 20
jahren rostig und es bildet sich einmal
rundherum der nagel wird lose und fällt
raus
ein bambus stiften gegner wird eins mit
dem holz des bootes solange das ganze
holz hält kannst das gut benutzen wenn
ein stück bricht kann ich es heraussägen
und ein neues stück einfügen
[Musik]
der hund ursprünglich aus tokio da hat
einen ganz verschiedene bürger kann aber
richtig frieden
irgendwann ist immer alles will wurde
beschlossen mit der familie gab es 200
[Musik]
sie hat erkannt und rauputz macht hat
ihm gezeigt
[Musik]
der sand beach bar mit der hinter dem
haus leckeren tomohiro sie zeigen das
aber nie vor
[Musik]
normales foto mohammed touristik mehr
gibt
hat sich dein leben verändert seit du
hilfst während ich in tokio arbeitete um
eine familie zu ernähren versteifte sich
meine innere haltung ich merkte ich
arbeite um zu überleben ohne arbeit kein
leben ohne geld kann er auf die ski
partie änderte sich meine mentalität
dann langsam
es funktioniert auch anders und
einfacher oder der natur rundherum
erhält man ja wasser und nahrung anbauen
damit man essen und überleben kann die
dinge sind da und du kannst anfangen zu
leben und hast zeit für die familie
was muss ich wissen bevor ich ins wasser
springen macht druckausgleich wenn du
abtausch kannst du das
[Musik]
judith
ich verstehe was tomohiro meint meiner
seite hier mädchen frank emmel und
weiterhin das paradies gefunden person
ist größer tochter delta
oder ist hier auf ishigaki geboren
es gibt kaum einschränkungen wir können
unsere familien seit selber gestalten
nachbarn sind wie eine erweiterte
familie wir sind glücklich
[Musik]
wer nicht das wichtigste hast du heute
zwar weniger aber deine leben ist viel
besser dasteht
ich finde glück hängen vom anhäufen von
vielen dingen ab
ein neuer fokus wie mache ich mein leben
reicher wie cayo eine tiefere erfüllung
finden mit dem was ich habe
das machen wir viel glücklicher ich
spiel vor bald sechs wochen los gezogen
sabine fotokamera entdecken und zwar auf
einen ort immer zuständig
philippsburg machen aber das land und
china science spiel so viele
verschiedene mancher begegnet nächsten
jahr erwartet
die helme der blick geht ins leere
japan mit maschinen trotzdem in
frankleben aber ich verstand nach der
rest doch schon mit besser und da ist
sie ganz sicher ich bin wieder zurück um
irgendwo der 43 hat das land die
menschen gebracht
[Musik]